now as the house lights darkened the
orchestra descends into the pit and
slowly the curtain rises to disclose a
stunning stage setting dominated by a
huge replica of the hero of the evening
the Academy Oscar and just in front of
it a whole table full of those coveted
award
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Charles Brackett
ladies and gentlemen at any official
meeting this year whether it be a big
steel or the girdle trust it is
customary to take a glance of a
half-centuries development in the field
of endeavor of those convening in the
case of motion pictures
I find the temptation to do so
irresistible our medium the newsreel
part of it has caught and preserved the
50 years with accuracy and impersonality
because of the evidence in film vaults
no one can ever picture the epoch in
pretty stylized
terms such as surround 18th century
England or the Currier and Ives America
of a hundred years ago we are not
celebrated as was an era of France in
great majestic tapestries we are there
Unseld I'd looking rather funny to the
eye of posterity funny but human and
understandable
I hope posterity will study us quite a
lot what about the other aspect of our
medium how have we developed as an art
fifty years ago the highest emotion
moving pictures could evoke in an
audience was terror at the charge of an
unerring train in contrast examine the
product of the year we have under
consideration tonight the five nominated
pictures were nominated by our members
explore a stunning variety of subjects a
an aspect of the American political
scene be the recent war from two
different angles see a delicate
psychological study from the pen of a
great American novelist Dee a
cross-section of an American suburb
observed with contemporary wit and
accuracy in addition and occurring
frequently on our nominations lists are
for fine pictures dealing in high
compassion with the problems of our
Negro citizens this is long and
honorable progress scrutiny of the 22
years of academy nominations
bears out this theory of the maturing
screen and the maturing appetites of
picture audiences not the fun and
nonsense which is an essential part of
show business is being neglected no year
which boasted I was a male war bride and
a musical is exuberant as on the town
can be accused of being unduly sour I
emphasized the consideration of graver
matters because we live in a time when
our civilization if it is to survive
must survive through some grave
exaltation of the human spirit some
kinder and wiser doctrine than the other
side of the world can show for that
spirit for that doctrine may Motion
Pictures be a strong and dedicated
instrument and now ladies and gentlemen
may I introduce as our master of
ceremonies tonight the man who
shouldered his way into the affection of
the picture public is the richly human
mug in a letter the 3.y mr. Paul
thank you thank you and good evening
ladies and gentlemen when the Board of
Governors of the Academy we're looking
for what they call a fresh and exciting
new personality to emcee this show every
one of the meeting yelled out in unison
yet Douglas well we all know how busy
Kirk is this is my first Academy show
I'm a stranger here so I'll handle the
pitch the best way I can how in past
years when I listened to the show I
always wish they tell us something about
you know how it all works about nobody
knowing who the winners are until the
envelopes are opened right here on the
stage well I've been briefed the
envelopes are sealed and brought to us
from the auditing firm of Price
Waterhouse where the returns have been
properly counted and certified a 12,000
people took part in the voting this year
the nominations were distinguished
achievement were made by the members of
the Academy branches assisted by the
Hollywood guild the final selections
were voted by the 1893 members of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences however one of the reasons I
never quite believed that nobody knew
the winners beforehand is the fact that
the orchestra always plays exactly the
right piece of music a split second
after the winners name is called well
it's true now I'd like to report a bit
of personal investigation i snooped I
found out all about it the conductor
Robert Emmett Dolan and his musicians
have 134 pieces of music in their books
one for every nomination in each
category as the nominations are read for
each award the musicians have all the
appropriate music fanned out on their
racks when the winner is announced the
conductor gives the downbeat and exactly
the time it takes the musicians to grab
the right music that's all there is to
it really now
a word if I may to the potential winners
a word speeches mm-hmm mr. Robert
Montgomery touched on this point last
year mr. Montgomery and eminent actor
good dresser you see it's the custom
with nice people that when something
good happens to them they like to thank
everyone who had anything to do with
bringing it about well this of course is
true however all of us know the teamwork
that must go into a fine picture so
right here and now on behalf of the
winners permit me to thank your
cameraman your writer your director your
hairdresser office your makeup man your
Griffin your producer and if I may I
will also assume that without your
mother the whole thing might not have
been possible so if it's all right with
you we'll adopt a sort of loose rule you
just thank your lucky stars the voters
and no one else please